bonsoir michel fize merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors quel bilan vous
faites de cette année plutôt mouvementée
je crois que notre reportage à pointer
les différentes manifestations
traduisant cette france qui est
décidément bien malade
à l'image du monde qui ne se porte guère
mieux
alors c'est vrai que cette année 2020
aura quand même été marqué par l'extrême
visibilité de la crise sanitaire
au point d'ailleurs que peut être dans
quelques temps on parlera de la
révolution du 17 mars pour montrer que
nous avons basculé avec cette épidémie
du monde d'avant vers le monde d'après
en espérant que ce monde d'après ne sera
qu'un monde qu'un monde provisoire
lorsque cette crise sanitaire a masqué
je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises ici
même sur votre antenne
c'est cette formidable crise économique
et sociale qui couve et qui absorbe
toutes les catégories sociales les unes
après les autres
j'avais dit encore sur cette antenne ya
près de deux ans qu'il n'y avait pas une
catégorie sociale aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
soient pas concernés par une difficulté
je n'avais évidemment pas penser à
l'arrivée de la commune 19 qui a fait
rentrer dans le camp des catégories
sinistrés les restaurateurs les gens du
spectacle bons qui sont aujourd'hui
probablement parmi les plus pénalisées
il faut aussi rappeler que malgré une
moindre visibilité
les gilets jaunes sont toujours là comme
la petite flamme la conscience d'une
colère qui est toujours là à la hauteur
je crois d'une crise économique et
sociale dont nous ne verrons
probablement les formidable impact que
dans quelques mois quand nous parlerons
j'espère un peu moins de crises
sanitaires
un temps fort tout de même que vous
retenez
je crois que le temps fort est à placer
sans doute aussi du côté du social du
côté des discriminations qu'elle soit
policière ou qu'elles soient liées à la
couleur de peau vous avez rappelé
évidemment les marches américaine contre
les violences policières
la marche ici contre contre le racisme
et toutes les discriminations
je pense que cette société est une
société fragmentée et qui est minée par
tous non respect des valeurs qui
permettent le vivre ensemble c'est à
dire la tolérance le respect de l'autre
quel qu'il soit dans ses origines
multiples dans ses comportements
multiples je pense que là il ya une
grande fracture de la société qu'il
faudra à tout prix résorber au plus vite
or justement lorsque vous parlez de
fractures de la société lorsque l'on
évoque les mouvements contre les
violences policières notamment la loi
sécurité globale plus récemment beaucoup
de manifestations parfois même émaillés
de heurts
est-ce que cela a un lien avec la
tradition des mouvements sociaux en
france
savez je pense que le besoin d'ordre ne
doit pas conduire à des excès dans
l'utilisation de la force
je crois qu'on a toujours beaucoup de
mal en france a assuré la conciliation
des libertés publiques et notamment des
libertés individuelles et de la
nécessaire paix sociale c'est un
exercice toujours toujours fragile mais
je crois qu'il faut rappeler encore une
fois que les fonctionnaires de l'état
quel qu'il soit content
une double exigence de maintien de
l'ordre bien sûr quand ils sont
policiers ou gendarmes mais aussi
d'exemplarité
voilà alors je crois que la
manifestation c'est dans la tradition
française
un peuple démocratique est un peuple
en france depuis maintenant quelques
quelques siècles est un peuple qui a le
droit de manifester et d'exprimer ses
divergences
je crois que je l'avais dit la semaine
dernière nous avons maintenant un second
pouvoir à une sorte de filet le
conducteur dans la rue un qui nous
rappelle constamment que la démocratie
c'est la sphère de tous que les
problèmes sont des problèmes qui
n'appartiennent pas à une classe
politique qui serait censée les résoudre
face à des citoyens qui seraient
condamnés à les subir
voilà je pense que nous devons tous nous
emparer de ces problèmes et surtout
éviter d'attendre qu'il ne prenne un
caractère d'urgence
il faut que la politique soit enfin je
crois pour demain le traitement de
toutes les questions avant que le ciel
ne nous tombe sur la tête car tous ces
problèmes qui sont là aujourd'hui sur le
devant de la scène sont connus et depuis
fort longtemps
alors vous le dit très souvent la france
elle est régulièrement secoué par des
mouvements sociaux depuis notamment 68
ce n'est pas prêt de se terminer qu'est
ce qui nous attend en 2021
je crois qu'en 2021 on va probablement
découvrir le choc économique et sociale
dans toute sa violence parce que
derrière ces images est spectaculaire il
y à ses millions et millions de français
et je pense pas simplement aux 10
millions de pauvres
il y à tous ceux qui sont dans des états
de précarité et qui sont dans des
situations inadmissibles dans une
démocratie c'est à dire dans une
situation de survie
donc je pense que tous les milliards qui
ont été déversées depuis maintenant
quelques mois je crois devrait aussi
prendre le chemin des questions des
questions sociales
il n'est pas normal que des catégories
soit encore une fois condamné à voir
je pense aux pensions de retraite avoir
des augmentations de 0,3 pour cent comme
si c'était véritablement une faveur de
l'état à avoir les personnes au smic
dans des situations qui ne permettent
pas de se loger se loger décemment
donc je pense qu'il faut relever le
niveau du social et surtout relever le
niveau de l'intérêt du pouvoir politique
pour les questions sociales qui ne sont
pas des questions mineures des questions
secondaires qui sont je crois des
questions principales essentiel même
merci beaucoup à vous michel fize je
rappelle que vous êtes un sociologue